bonjour alexandre vincent des merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin sur rtl france
on va parler de ce que préconise valérie
pécresse là la présidente de la région
ile-de-france avancé les vacances
scolaires de 15 jours pour tenter
d'endiguer en tout cas l'afflux dans les
réanimations en ile de france qu'en
pensez vous je pense qu'il faut fermer
les écoles en dernier recours on l'a vu
lors du premier confinement il ya un an
des conséquences dramatiques des
fermetures de l'ensemble des écoles sur
le territoire national je pense que ça
nous a fait vraiment en cat extrême
d'extrême urgence aujourd'hui
visiblement je pense quand même qu'il
faut encore tenir parce que c'est
l'avenir de nos enfants dont il est
question salée je suis maire d'une ville
populaire d'une ville s'appelle
rillieux-la-pape qu'on n'a pas de 55 %
de logements sociaux et j'ai vu les
dégâts monumentale que la fermeture des
écoles a fait c'est pour ça qu'en tout
cas je pense qu'il ne faut surtout pas
fermer les écoles ou en tout cas qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on n'est vraiment pas
le choix il faut essayer de faire en
sorte de maintenir cette continuité
éducative alors heureusement dans le
cadre de ce second film ans et mesure de
freinage comme selon la formule
consacrée par le gouvernement
actuellement il ya comme les vacances
scolaires qui sont milieu profitons de
ce moment là pour vous les avancées les
avants c'est donc ce n'est pas une bonne
solution ça fera un mois de vacances
pour vous ce serait trop mais je pense
que ça y est on a déjà quasiment j'ai
des enfants qui l'année dernière ont
quasiment eu six mois sans école cette
pandémie
on sait qu'à un moment il va s'arrêter
par contre l'avis des enfants elle va
continuer et les dégâts qui ont été
occasionnés de pas quand on ne les
rattrapera pas et je peux vous le dire
plus vous faites parti des classes
populaires plus les dégâts sont
importants plus le décrochage est
inéluctable donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut maintenir cette continuité
éducative et c'est pas en mettant deux
semaines de vacances de plus qu'on
cassera l'épidémie l'épidémie à la casse
sera en vaccinant massivement alors ça
tout le monde le dit et on attend
évidemment ces vaccins en attendant il
ya ce confinement qui ne ressemble pas
vraiment un confinement qui a été mis en
place vers royal a tall s'est exprimé à
ce sujet hier il dit les mots
mesures sont bonnes si les français les
respecte écouter le porte parole du
gouvernement
puisqu'on se contamine peu en extérieur
et que les beaux jours arrivent nous ne
mettons aucune limite de temps dans la
journée à la présence dehors et nous
reculons d'une heure le couvre-feu
anticipant ainsi le changement d'heure
et passage à l'heure d'été qui
interviendra prochainement ce sont des
mesures équilibrées des mesures logique
des mesures de bon sens des mesures
efficaces si elles sont pleinement
appliqué si elles sont pleinement s à
appliquer ça veut dire que tout repose
finalement sur le bon vouloir des
français qu'en pensez vous
c'est pas moi c'est pas le bon vouloir
c'est la responsabilité de chacun
quand on est dans une vie quand on vit
en société on a bien sûr la
responsabilité collective mais aussi on
a la responsabilité individuelle
on est responsable de soi et de ses
actes et moi je pense que c'est à chacun
d'entre nous d'être extrêmement
responsables d'être extrêmement prudent
de faire attention de ne pas être trop
dans une pièce de mettre le masque quand
cela est nécessaire de continuer avec
les gestes barrières et la distanciation
physique c'est important d'appliquer ces
règles et puis c'est bien aussi se
défausser de dire voici sa marche pas
c'est parce que peut-être que les
français n'ont pas respectés alors que
six français sur dix disent qu'ils
auraient préféré à un confinement dur en
janvier n'aurait-il pas fallu qu'elle se
lâche moi je suis je suis toujours moi
je suis je suis toujours très sûr ce
genre de chantage je fais toujours très
attention
vous savez quand vous êtes maire vous
gouvernez pas avec des sondages ou
gouverner avec le comédien avec avec des
cons il ya des vrais gens qui parlent
réellement dans la rue ou lors des
réunions et je peux vous dire que les
français sont justement ça fait un an
qu'ils sont enfermés avec eux allez on
rouvre tout on referme tout le monde
chez soi on met un confinement ont des
consignes mais vous avez des règles
contraignantes
c'est aujourd'hui les français quand
vous regardez ils vont au travail et ils
rentrent chez eux il ya plus de loisirs
il ya plus de moments de respiration
donc scellé après ceux qui disent ah
mais on aurait dû confiner beaucoup plus
durement encore plus en avant
je je je fais très attention ça c'est
des commentaires en général de personnes
qui dans son salon parisien et qui a pas
les contraintes d'une vie de famille ou
au dividende en le vendant 1 dans un
appartement exigu en hlm
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui chacun doit
être responsable de ses actes
évidemment le gouvernement doit prendre
des mesures et il les prend aussi mais
je pense que c'est une responsabilité
collective que nous avons tous et encore
une fois si nous n'augmentons pas la
vaccination je crois savoir qu
aujourd'hui à une réunion au niveau de
l'europe pour empêcher les exportations
freiner les exportations de vaccins qui
sont produits sur le territoire européen
nous n'en sortirons pas et aujourd'hui
il est important qu'on arrive à
rattraper ce qu'ont fait d'autres pays
développés
regardez ce qui se passe en
grande-bretagne regardez ce qui se passe
en israël où la vie commence à reprendre
ses droits et donc le vaccin parce les
leçons mais parce qu'elles ont des
vaccins la belgique elle reconfirme
l'allemagne aussi parce que justement
c'est compliqué et qu'ils n'ont pas de
vaccin comme la france le problème moi
je vais vous dire c'est que moi je le
vois partir moi je me suis battu dès le
2 janvier dernier pour avoir un centre
de vaccination dans ma dans ma commune
et on a été beaucoup de maires à se
battre et peu de maires en obtenir à on
and on nous avait annoncé 360 doses par
semaine dès la première semaine
au bout de quatre jours d'accord pas à
pas par rapport au bout de trois
semaines
au bout de quatre jours alors que tous
les rendez vous était pris on est tombé
accrochez vous bien à 90 doses
d'accord on est remonté aujourd'hui à
300 péniblement au bout de plusieurs
semaines --le à partir de la semaine
prochaine
on monte à 500 doses on est capable
d'aller plus fort et plus loin donc moi
je crois à une chose c'est ça les vaut
couple préfets maires nous on sait faire
la logistique les communes et c'est le
cas de ma commune on est en train de
mettre des moyens énormes a même recruté
une personne au niveau de la mairie pour
quoi faire tourner justement le centre
de vaccination donc nous on met les
moyens les collectivités on a toujours
été au rendez vous et on va continuer à
l'être parce que nous sommes la
république de proximité donc il faut
aussi que l'état ne fasse confiance et
je pense par contre vraiment que si on
arrive à respecter ce couple préfet
maire que les états font leur travail
nous fournissent des doses et que de
l'autre côté on fasse confiance aux
collectivités et on fait confiance aux
français qui ne sont pas des enfants
alors on verra le bout du tunnel alors
xavier bertrand président des
hauts-de-seine a officialisé sa
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
sans passer par la case primaire
qu'en pensez vous il a eu bien raison
savez xavier bertrand il a été
secrétaire général de notre famille
politique
à l'époque quand cela s'appelait l'ump
il était minuit
de nicolas sarkozy ministre de jacques
chirac il aujourd'hui
président d'une grande région cette
candidature
elle était annoncée elle était attendue
elle était souhaitée par certains
aujourd'hui xavier bertrand et bien a
dévoilé son calendrier
une partie du programme qu'il souhaitait
en tout cas défendre du projet qui
souhaitait défendre devant les français
et le fait qu'aujourd'hui ils soient
enfin candidat eh bien je pense que
c'est une très bonne chose pour notre
famille politique et ça peut nous
permettre aujourd'hui de faire en sorte
que la droite se reconstruise se
reconstruise essaye de passer via le
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
parce que je vous rappellerai que ce qui
a affaibli d'autres familles politiques
en 2017 c'est le fait qu'elle n'ait pas
été présente au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle ce qui était
une première depuis la création de la
vème république
ça veut dire qu'il aura pas de primaires
à droite ça le débat est ouvert au sein
du parti
moi je vais vous dire les choses sont
très claires je suis de toute façon anti
primaire on a vu que ça nous a menés
on est dans une famille gaulliste on est
issu du gaullisme et la volonté du
général de gaulle à l'époque c'était la
rencontre entre un homme au dessus des
partis et est un homme son projet et le
peuple
alors justement place à l'esprit de la
vème république nous sommes la famille
politique qui skie équipe qui a créé la
vème république
d'accord je pense qu'à partir de ce
moment là ont aussi respecté son esprit
et qu'on sorte un petit peu des jeux
partisans et des manoeuvres
sinon et bien les mêmes causes ont les
mêmes conséquences à savoir qu'on risque
de ne pas être au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle sur la des candidatures
multiples si on ne change pas derrière
le meilleur candidat qui aujourd'hui
xavier bertrand les dernières enquêtes
d'opinion montrent que c'est celui qui
face à marine le pen au deuxième tour de
l'élection gagnerait avec le plus de
marge
donc je pense que désormais il faut
qu'on arrête les chicaillas on se range
derrière le meilleur candidat celui qui
a je pense aujourd'hui le plus de
détermination à proposer un programme
français et ce candidat aujourd'hui
c'est xavier bertrand on le verra merci
en tout cas alexandre vincent des
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct sur
arte france